plato's great discovery was as
groundbreaking as it was momentous with his
teaching of ideas he shaped the entire
occidental culture
his name is still
known all over the world and more than 2000
years ago he expressed an enormous suspicion in his allegory of the cave
that
people saw many shadows  on a
high wall and take these shadows to
be real figures
with this parable, plato wanted to shake his
contemporaries awake no longer
to live in a manipulated illusory world to
be blinded without recognizing the
real world
the athena would
draw from material wealth from the pleasures of
completely dazzle demagogic politicians and
allow them to be duped
his suspicion is astonishingly topical, especially today in the
digital age
do we not also run the risk of
losing ourselves in media shades and projections through internet mobile tv consumption in
order to recognize the truth so
plato man has to learn again  to see things with the
inner eye
we are able to feel the truth
if we only manage
to look behind the mere appearances
because behind the everyday world surrounding us
and the visibly
vivid world there is a second
invisible reality a kind of higher
scientific level the  the true world can
reveal to us this second reality
is so flat the realm of ideas,
especially the idea of the good, true and b
autiful that we should orientate ourselves by, but
w
at exactly are these ideas, where do th
y come from, do we have them before we were born or ha
e we always had something  says plato
when he talks about the good
and above all how can we recognize it
and lead a corresponding life the
book platform in 60 minutes explains
in particular
questions about the sun and
the cave plato's fascinating
world of ideas but also his great
political vision of the ideal state  with
philosophers kings at the helm, is
based on the wich  The most quotes
presented in the chapter What is Plato still useful to
us today shows the
astonishing topicality and explosiveness of
a philosophy that Plato wrote about 2500
years ago